fleur pellerin ministre délégué aux pme
et à l'économie numérique est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir ça et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation les
français vous découvre encore mais votre
combat le mot n'est pas trop fort contre
les géants du net vous expose fleur
pellerin de plus en plus nous en
parlerons d'ailleurs avec tupac pointu
de l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire tout à l'heure et puis
perrine tarneaud de public sénat nous
rejoindra ensuite nous aidera vous
aidera aussi à mieux vous dévoiler
puisque votre histoire personnelle et
fascinante et pas seulement pour les
coréens comme l'a écrit il ya quelques
jours le new york times
vous avez un point commun j'ai découvert
avec jean marc ayrault vous parler
allemand vous avez fait un vainqueur six
franco-allemand est alors qu'ils
connaissent
qu'est ce que signifie pour une femme de
votre génération c'est-à-dire mener il y
a bien moins de 50 ans je leurs pèlerins
bien 50 ans d'amitié qui sont célébrés à
berlin là c'est très importante parce
que je crois que nous appartenons à une
génération pour laquelle la relation
franco-allemande a été structuré anton
la construction européenne alors moi
j'ai été particulièrement sensibilisés à
cette question puisque j'ai fait toute
ma scolarité dans un collège puis au
lycée franco-allemand ou donc la
relation franco allemande était
évidemment très importante j'ai passé
tous mes étés de la 6e à un terminal
chez des correspondants allemands et
donc j'ai un attachement particulier à
la plage naturelle en tous les cas il
n'y a évidemment pour vous françois
hollande est vu par jean françois copé
qu'il l'a dit à berlin lors d'un
discours comme le responsable personnel
de la dégradation du tandem
franco-allemand qu'est ce que vous
répondez au président de l'ump
je trouve ça assez pitoyable je trouve
ça assez pitoyable les mots employés je
trouve assez pitoyable l'attitude de
french bashing qui fait beaucoup de mal
à notre pays pas seulement d'ailleurs au
gouvernement mais aussi à l'économie
dans son ensemble à tous les acteurs
économique je trouve ça très au fait de
ce livre
oui je trouve que parler à l'étranger en
de manière extrêmement critiques de la
france de de pas seulement la politique
du gouvernement ce qui est mis en cause
c'est vraiment d'ailleurs la politique
menée par ses propres amis puisqu'ils
mais il met en cause les politiques qui
sont menées depuis dix ans chance c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas très
constructif à l'étranger qu'on ait un
débat interne sur ces sujets là sur la
compétitivité sur les choix politiques
je trouve ça très sain c'est la
démocratie ce sont des sens même mais à
l'étranger je trouve que c'est très
contre-productif et ça donne une très
mauvaise image de notre pays
en tous les cas de françois hollande
françois hollande et jean françois copé
en espagne de jean françois copé pour
vous d'abord bien sûr on vous a compris
pitoyable dit vous jean françois
hollande que vous avez accompagné de
très près 1 pendant la campagne
présidentielle
déjà sur le dossier du numérique a
endossé depuis quelques semaines
maintenant les habits de chef de choeur
est ce qu'il vous surprend non il ne me
surprend pas parce que j'ai toujours
trouvé assez erronée le procès en
stature en manque de stature que la
décision manque de courage au monde du
courage que lui faisait nos opposants
politiques pendant la campagne je crois
que ces voix là c'est un chef d'état qui
sait prendre des décisions qui s'est
engagée la france de manière réfléchie
et parent considéré comme ont pu le dire
certains certain nombre de l'opposition
voilà c'est une décision qui est
courageuse
j'ai parlé à une homo langage à une
homologue du gouvernement allemand hier
qui saluait aussi cette décision je
pense que c'était la bonne décision et
qu'il apprécie courageusement est dans
les temps alors un de vos collègues à
bien des difficultés à en ce moment
c'est vincent peillon avec sa réforme
des rythmes scolaires
le député ps jean-christophe cambadélis
estime que le ministre l'éducation
nationale n'a pas toujours le doigté
nécessaire
c'est lui qui le dit
qu'est-ce que vous dépendez cendres
votre collègue du gouvernement je crois
qu'ils ce décès se défendre tout sale
mais ce qui me paraît important c'est
d'avoir cette ce débat que vincent
peillon a ouvert sur l'action des
rythmes scolaires tous les
pédopsychiatres tous les spécialistes
sont relativement d'accord sur le fait
de dire que les avaliser les enfants nos
enfants ont trop d'heures de cours sur
les dérapages et les listes qui mène la
grève à paris ce mardi et qui est un
débat enfin moi je trouve ça plus
constructif d'avoir un débat et discuter
je pense que vincent peillon de même
cette réforme dans un esprit de
concertation et de consultation
alors qu' une greffe ont manifesté un
désaccord moi je trouve ça enfin je
respecte tout à fait là les syndicats et
la façon dont ils souhaitent exprimer
leur désaccord mais je pense qu'il faut
ensuite avancé réfléchir dans l'intérêt
de nos enfants
on a des heures de cours qui sont parmi
les plus élevés dans l' ocde
c'est vrai qu'il faut s'intéresser
d'abord au bon rythme scolaire et aubin
bon moyen d'apprendre aux enfants et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est important de
voir ce débat merci vous êtes sous le
même toit que d'autres ministres vous
êtes vous êtes assez nombreux mais on
peut lire alors en voici deux pierre
moscovici et arnaud montebourg de qui
vous sentez vous la plus proche
les deux les deux bords je connais des
pierres lorsque fils depuis bien plus
longtemps depuis prés de près de 15 ans
g j'ai fait la campagne de 2002 déjà à
ses côtés
ernault mais bon c'est plus une
découverte de la campagne je m'entends
très bien avec les deux différences et
leurs différences lui votre sensibilité
vous pousse quand même plus vers pierre
moscovici ce que je me trompe
vous savez on a un gouvernement qui est
dit l'air dans sa composition avec des
avis et des débats internes et au sein
de ce gouvernement il ya différentes
tendances qui s'exprime une fois que le
gouvernement ensuite a décidé quelque
chose que le premier ministre a arbitré
il y à une seule ligne
donc moi j'ai eu une discussion très
constructive avec arnaud montebourg je
pense que nous sommes d'accord sur la
majorité des sujets confié pourtant new
york times qui nous était difficile
souvent à l'étranger
elle vient d'expliquer la position
étatiste du ministre du redressement
productif
ce n'est pas du tout ça je crois que
c'est un raccourci de du lab europe 1
j'ai dit lorsque la même question avait
compris à une question des journalistes
qui ne demandait si c'était difficile de
défendre l'attractivité de la france à
l'étranger
j'ai dit que effectivement au moment du
projet de loi de finance du mouvement
des pigeons delà du débat sur la taxe à
75%
ça pouvait être compliqué parfois de
d'expliquer que la france rattrape enfin
est un territoire de travail parce que
vous-même ça coince fortement sa
position personnelle c'est que c'est il
y avait une incompréhension vous savez
il faut souvent faire beaucoup de
pédagogie à l'étranger parce que les
gens sont des raccourcis et donc ils
entendaient un débat avec d'ailleurs le
french bashing dont je parlais tout à
l'heure
y compris des français donc qui
s'exprimait à l'étranger en tant que
critique vis-à-vis des décisions du
gouvernement français évidemment à
l'étranger
ça donne un sentiment un peu de
confusion donc c'est plutôt ça que je
faisais allusion est ensuite certaines
personnes vont interpréter ça parce que
ça les arrangeait
je pense comme comme un point d'un écart
ou entre entre ombres et moi ce que ça
n'était absolument pas remis c'est
vraiment une invitation je refuse que la
taxe 75 % appartiennent au passé
aujourd'hui appartient pas complètement
passée c'était une engagement de
campagne on va se donner un peu le temps
de voir de quelle manière elle peut être
ne reviendra pas dans le port elle
dérape en l'état puisqu'elle a été
censuré par le constituent le conseil
constitutionnel on va réouvrir la
réflexion
le travail technique le mot
compétitivité et attractivité on vient
de voir reviennent souvent dans votre
discours
quant à la compétitivité bien c'est au
nom de la compétitivité que le
constructeur automobile renault dit
aujourd'hui au syndicat si vous
n'acceptez pas le pacte de compétitivité
qu'on vous propose c'est un
réaménagement du temps de travail gel
des salaires et bien on fermera deux
usines en france comment est-ce que vous
réagissez je trouve la méthode assez
désagréable parce que effectivement
comme comme l'a dit un monde où ça
s'apparente effectivement et fond de
chantage c'est à dire si vous n'acceptez
pas cet accord dont les termes exacts
que je vous dicte je vais faire mais moi
je trouve que c'est pas une façon de
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
donc je crois que même si je comprends
bien entendu que notamment la filière
automobile soit soumise à une très forte
pression de la concurrence
internationale et qu'elle ait des
impératifs de compétitivité je crois
qu'il ya un minimum de respect à avoir
pour les partenaires sociaux ce n'est
pas comme ça qu'on engage bien sûr
davantage
je trouve que c'est pas très correct à
la fermeture la suppression
supplémentaire dans quoi on sert villa
vous irez à davos en fin de semaine quel
sera votre mot d'excusé pour justifier
l'absence de françois hollande
écoutez je pense que vous pourriez
demander la même chose à nicolas sarkozy
qu'il n'y est pas allé à tous les ans
françois hollande il aura peut-être à un
autre moment je pense qu'actuellement il
ya quand même un calendrier ça ne vous
aura pas échappé internationale qui
exige quand même sa disponibilité en
france même si aujourd'hui ils célèbrent
le 50e anniversaire du traité de
l'elysée
je crois que c'est important pour le
chef de l'état en ce moment
particulièrement et par égard pour les
militaires qui sont engagés au mali
d'être d'être présent en france et je
pense que il sera bien représentée par
vent davos par une car moscovici n'a
jamais moi vous regrettez que les
français célèbrent les acteurs 1 mais
pas les chefs d'entreprise là j'ai bien
lu new york times 1 c'est bien alors
qu'ils pourriez vous citer vos com
comme chef d'entreprise créateur en la
matière écoutez moi j'ai évidemment une
tendresse et une affection particulière
pour des jeunes créateurs d'entreprises
qui sont souvent assez méconnu et là
j'ai été frappée je sais pas si vous
vous avez vous avez vu ça dans la presse
mais un jeune entrepreneur de
montpellier qui crée des des robots
d'assistance chirurgicale pour faire des
opérations moins invasive avec d'ondés
cicatrice plus petite et bien et est
classé dans une revue canadienne parmi
les dix personnalités les plus
innovantes de l'année avec mark
zuckerberg
voilà bertin naoum il s'appelle et je
trouve que son nom méconnu
j'ai vu aussi récemment alors là ça
vient de tout autre genre que sidney
toledano qui est le patron de dior qui
fait partie de la marque france aussi
qu'on essaye de promouvoir avec arnaud
montebourg nicole bricq et pierre
moscovici venait d'être classé parmi les
meilleurs ce patron du monde par aux
siens un magazine un classement
international du groupe de bernard
arnault qui a tenté de s'exiler en
belgique
je parle du manager j'ai parlé au
manager - classé parmi les meilleurs
managers je trouve que c'est cécile avio
niel de free non oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai il n'y a pas beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise qui ont créé
une groupe avec une telle une telle
croissance mais une telle croissance une
telle valorisation boursière en aussi
peu de temps et je crois que les success
stories comme celle là je pourrais citer
jacques antoine granjon vente privee.com
aussi où jean baptiste rudelle de criteo
qui sont là des entreprises très jeunes
qui ont moins de 15 ans et qui se sont
unis c'est vraiment dans les hauteurs
des palmarès les entreprises françaises
dont je trouve que ce sont de beaux
exemples et qu'on n'a pas assez comme ça
de l'exemple contre un mot aux états
unis par exemple beaucoup dé bon eh bien
oui julien demain nous est très beau
fortis ag criteo viens de réinstaller
des équipes de recherche et
développement en france donc ça c'est
agréable d'être à leur arrivée il ya un
domaine où vous êtes à l'offensive c'est
la piraterie fiscal dont se rendent
coupables les géants du net
est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer que le
fisc français réclame un milliard
d'euros à google 250 millions amazon
alors qu'une enquête et viserait ib je
vous confirme pas les chiffres bien
entendu puisque c'est une enquête
fiscale qui est en cours et donc je ne
commente pas les procédures fiscales
mais effectivement nous sommes bien
décidés à mener le combat contre ces
méthodes d'optimisation ces dispositifs
d'optimisation fiscale qui consiste à
déplacer les pays les profits de pays en
pays pour finalement échapper à toute
imposition au niveau mondial et qu'on
permet pas les chiffres mais bien qu'il
ya des redressement en cours
il ya jérôme cahuzac s'est exprimé sur
le sujet donc
il ya également des procédures en cours
pour vérifier s'il n'y a pas eu une
optimisation fiscale massive d'une
fraude fiscale massive de la part de ses
acteurs mais moi pas peur oui oui c'est
tout un groupe comme google par exemple
paye à moins de 5 % de l'impôt sur les
sociétés à l'échelle mondiale globale
sur son chiffre d'affaires dans le monde
entier donc c'est quand même c'est une
perte de recettes fiscales pour une pas
seulement la france mais pour les états
unis pour l'irlande pour tous les pays
dans lesquels transitent les ressources
les recettes de cette compagnie et
d'autre alors on va approfondir toutes
ces questions donc un qui provoque des
réactions multiples sur internet
notamment avec le toupet pointu et l
agence france presse qui va nous
rejoindre
d'abord tous les éléments de ce bras de
fer avec le google spécifiquement on
voit ça avec mathilde de bélanger le
gouvernement en guerre contre la
nouvelle piraterie fiscale l'expression
et de fleur pellerin ministre délégué au
numérique et les pirates ce sont les
géants du net google amazon facebook et
apple sont en ligne de mire
ces sites basés à l'étranger réalisent
d'énormes bénéfices en france mais ni
paye presque pas d'impôts
une injustice fiscale dont le sénateur
philippe marini a fait l'un de ses
sujets de prédilection selon lui le
manque à gagner pour l'état s'élèverait
à 1 milliard et demi d'euros pour ces
quatre entreprises chaque année on perd
beaucoup d'argent donc le sujet dont
nous parlons c'est un sujet qui doit
être traitée dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois et est
surtout au moment où me demain dont
beaucoup d'efforts à nos concitoyens
vendredi dernier deux experts mandatés
par le gouvernement ont remis un rapport
sur cette question
leur solution est inédite taxer les
entreprises du numérique sur leur
utilisation des données personnelles des
utilisateurs des informations
stratégiques qui ont une vraie valeur
marchande pour ces entreprises
aujourd'hui on valorise une entreprise
sur l'argent qu'elle gagne ou sur son
patrimoine matériel
demain la valorisation des entreprises
ce sera plus sur ces éléments la sueur
du patrimoine
hier le nombre d'utilisateurs des
millions d'utilisateurs qu'elles ont où
se un patrimoine immatériel avantages de
ce rapport c'est qu'ils pointent ce
changement de fou mais la france ne
pourra pas mener seul ce combat d'autres
états comme le royaume uni l'allemagne
ou les etats-unis ont aussi commencé et
réfléchir et c'est l'autre
préconisations du rapport trouver une
solution à l'échelon international et
européen
google n'a juste eura pa l'ajusterait en
aucune manière son comportement mondial
parce qu'il y aura une nouvelle loi
fiscale en france qui ne fera que que
régler une petite partie des sujets mais
la loi nationale est très importante
parce que c'est au niveau national que
le débat a lieu la proposition de loi de
philippe marini sera examiné le 31
janvier au sénat
cette question sera à l'ordre du jour de
la réunion du g20 finances à moscou
février où l' ocde présentera un plan
d'action contre l'évasion fiscale des
multinationales
voilà donc le dossier devient
international fair pèlerins sait-on que
tupac points clés de l'agencé france
presse et qui nous à rejoindre soir que
pas de vos questions à la ministre de
l'économie numérique et des pme on les
oublie pas et d'innovation est de
l'innovation ça va avec le numérique
holtz et alors on vient de vous être
rendu sur la fiscalité du numérique dans
votre vie quelle est la marge de
manoeuvre de la france dans ce domaine
que peut faire donc un pays comme la
france face à un géant comme aiment à
des géants comme google facebook ou
twitter alors ils seront je crois qu'il
ya plusieurs il ya plusieurs niveaux
d'intervention tout d'abord le
le reportage le montrait il ya un niveau
international
et là il ya une accélération des choses
je pense que la france d'ailleurs est
assez motrice dans cette accélération
des choses parce que nous avons des
discussions avec la grande avec le
royaume uni et l'allemagne notamment ne
si l'italie et l'espagne sur ces sujets
puisque tout le monde est d et comme je
disais tout à l'heure sur en matière
d'optimisation fiscale des
multinationales
donc il ya déjà à 1 go une initiative
qui peut être lancée au niveau du dos et
des oeufs et la france souhaitent être
très motrice dans ce travail qui est
effectué actuellement il sera porté par
le g20 je pense que c'est important et
notamment pour pouvoir appréhender
puisque comme ce sont des mouvements
internationaux il faut bien sûr se
regrouper pour pouvoir mieux appréhender
les revenus à l'échelle mondiale donc ça
c'est la première étape relancer cette
initiative dont le reportage parlait qui
s'appelle érosion des bases et des
placements des profits donc ce sont des
mécanismes d'optimisation fitial par les
cales des grandes multinationales des
places dans des états tunez vous avez
des états tunnel leurs profits pour
finir par le payer aucun impôt ou loger
tous leurs bénéfices dans des paradis
fiscaux comme calmer les gens non non
vous avez une entreprise comme starbucks
fait la même chose parce qu'elle lui l
utilise une technique de prix de
transfert qui permet ainsi de
délocaliser les profils des cas cette
initiative qui va être vraiment très
fortement réactiver dans le cadre de l'
ocde et dans le cadre du g20
au niveau national la proposition
principale du rapport colin et colin qui
s'appelle comme ça et de taxer ces
acteurs du web à partir des données
personnelles qu'ils utilisent sur
lesquels ils s'enrichissent en les
utilisant les collectant et en les
exploitant
c'est une initiative qui est inédite
c'est une initiative inédite et c'est
sans doute pour trouver une solution
transitoire en attendant de trouver une
solution internationale parce que moi je
pense que la solution nationale et
européenne
il faut avoir de l'imagination en
matière fiscale j'ai pour être clair les
gens ne comprennent pas forcément dire
que ces entreprises seraient taxées sur
les données qu'elles collectent sur nous
parce que c'est nous qui les fournissent
les conditions supprimer 1
l'idée c'est de dire qu'il ya un travail
gratuit qui est fournie par les
utilisateurs de ces plateformes de ces
réseaux sociaux en fournissant des
données à partir duquel se sont elles
pleinement du web où ces voix là est la
matière première et c'est de là
la ressource totalement gratuite
contrairement à l'énergie ou à la
naissance par exemple c'est la ressource
totalement gratuite qui est fournie par
les utilisateurs et qui ensuite être
utilisés par des moteurs de recherche et
pour faire de la publicité ciblée pour
faire proposer des services et donc
l'idée c'est effectivement de taxer
alors il faut vous retrouvez les
modalités techniques ce qui n'est pas
évident mais de taxer l'utilisation
faite par ces entreprises des données
publiques des données privées des
utilisateurs lorsqu'elles ne sont pas
ouverts parce qu'elles sont conscientes
des risques au niveau des libertés de
chacun au niveau de la cnil ne pourrait
pas s'opposer à ce type d'initiative par
exemple la ceinture de données de chacun
c'est un travail qu'on fait on mènera
bien sûr en association avec la cnil
mais c'est moins dangereux qu enfin ça
sera admise et bien entendu et c'est
moins dangereux que d'avoir des données
privées qui sont actuellement utilisées
sans grande transparence par des acteurs
dont vous ne savez pas très bien ce
qu'ils font avec vos données déjà ces
grands acteurs du net ne sont pas
vertueux il y a peu de temps un de ses
acteurs a fait l'objet d'une observation
de la part du g29 qui regroupe les 29
villes des pays européens et au delà
parce que des manipulations qu'il
opérera sur les données publiques les
données privées pardon et données
privées des utilisateurs n'étaient pas
faites dans la plus grande transparence
et un et en informant correctement les
utilisateurs donc actuellement les
pratiques ne sont pas forcément ne sont
pas forcément très très transparente
plus plus largement dans l'impression
que tout le monde demande de l'argent à
google dernièrement les producteurs de
musique ont demandé leur taxe google
vous allez ce week-end à au midem à
cannes qu'est ce que vous comptez leur
dire aux producteurs de musique
je crois que je n'aurais donc frapper à
la porte aux éditeurs de presse
on pose une question qui me paraît très
importante c'est la question la
répartition nahla des revenus en la
chaîne de valve de la valeur ajoutée
dans la chaîne aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'avec l'économie numérique et une
transformation totale depuis la
production des contenus jusqu'à leur
diffusion auprès des consommateurs il ya
des acteurs qui se sont qui sont qui
interviennent à différents stades de la
chaîne et la chaîne de valeur c'est
défendre au profit de certains d'entre
eux qui sont en petit nombre et qui sont
surtout c'est vrai c'est plate forme où
ces prestataires de services internet
comme
comme on dit et donc à une vraie
réflexion à avoir sur le partage de la
valeur ajoutée c'est la logique qui est
que toute la valeur ajoutée qui est
produite par l'ensemble des acteurs
soient captés uniquement par une seule
catégorie d'acteurs et donc moi je
n'aime pas tellement la proche en silo
parce que je pense qu'il faut c'est à
dire être traiter la problématique de la
presse traiter la problématique de la
musique parce qu'après il ya le cinéma
il ya les blogs il ya des blogueurs
aussi à la bd il ya deux jeux vidéo et
je trouve qu'il vaut mieux essayer de et
c'est pour ça que l' approche fiscale me
paraît être la bonne puisque en plus
elle pose le problème des kits à un
problème d'équité
ça me paraît être une bonne solution
d'essayer de taxer les la valeur hookaew
les bénéfices de ces entreprises qui
pour l'instant ne participent pas du
tout à un rôle également ils ont le
droit ils peuvent demander ça à
prétendre à ça je pense qu'il serait
utile alimente en tout cas le débat est
certaine forme de pression pour que on
les encourage et vous même d'ailleurs
mais non ce qu'on va contre google
oui peut-être moi je souhaite poser je
souhaite poser les bonnes questions
surtout trouver des réponses
justement les éditeurs de presse
négocient depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant avec google est ce que vous
pensez qu'on va parvenir à un accord
avant la fin du mois des négocient
depuis le début du mois de décembre donc
ça fait pas très très longtemps parce
que moi et donc ça effectivement là on a
souhaité que cette cette médiation
puisse s'achever à la fin du mois de
janvier
voilà je crois que nicolas
discussions sont en cours on verra bien
si elle n'aboutit c'est la dèche et on
avisera en légiférant malgré les
déclarations récentes du président de la
république on dit que le gouvernement
est un peu embêté avec l'idée d'une loi
parce que juridiquement ça l'idée des
droits voisins ne tiendra pas la route
présent lundi qu'on légifère ray on
trouvera le moyen de légiférer
efficacement sur pour un autre ex pour
parler d'un autre acteur de dunettes
twitter il ya quelques jours une
audience opposés devant les tribunaux
l'uejf à twitter qui lui reprochaient
notamment l'utilisation de hashtag
raciste antisémite
la décision va être rendue jeudi quelle
est votre position sur ce dossier
j'ai une position moins de principe qui
est de dire il n'y a pas de raison que
la loi pénale française ne s'applique
pas sur sur le territoire français qui
soit virtuel ou réel
si vous êtes à la télévision et que vous
proférez née des propos à caractère
antisémite ou incitant à la haine
raciale vous allez être condamné donc si
vous le faites sur twitter à partir du
territoire français et à destination
d'un public français n'y a pas vraiment
de raison que ça ne soit pas également
le cas maintenant c'est vrai que
juridiquement c'est assez difficile à
mettre en place pour des raisons qui
tiennent au statut d'hébergeur de
twitter qui tiennent aux procédures de
coopération judiciaire entre la france
et les états unis donc c'est vrai que
c'est difficile à mettre en place mais
sur le plan des principes je trouve que
la loi devrait s'appliquer à tous de la
même façon que ce soit dans l'espace
public physiques ou virtuels parce que
twitter s'abrite derrière la loi
américaine en disant que les données
sont hébergées et stockés là bas donc le
droit français ne peut pas s'appliquer à
twitter c'est ce que disent twitter
c'est en tout cas c'est leur ligne de
défense on verra bien ce que décidera la
justice après il ya aussi des coupes
procédures de coopération qui ont déjà
été mises en oeuvre par le passé c'est à
dire le juge français prend une décision
il a fait appliquer ensuite par le juge
américain dont c'est évidemment à
un peu plus procédurale et procédurier
et ça prend plus de temps
moi je souhaiterais est d'ailleurs le
sens des discussions que j'ai avec
twitter convaincante quand je m'adresse
à eux je trouve qu'on peut trouver des
solutions qui leur permettent de
s'adapter ou voilà au droit aux droits
locaux
c'est une question qui ne se pose pas
qu'en france elle se pose dans d'autres
pays et je pense qu'il faut il faut
trouver le moyen de leur permettre de
s'adapter à l'éthique et aux principes
républicains qui fondent les valeurs
d'un côté tingwick semblant d'être
choqués vous même quand vous allez voir
un peu ce qui se passe sur twitter de ne
pas souvent parce que enfin moi je suis
j'utilise aussi twitter dans la mesure
où mon temps me le permet mais c'est
quand même un vecteur formidable des
changes de ses très réactif et voilà je
pense que si ces antisémites et
représente quand même un iota parmi le
reste et twitter a apporté une
innovation qui est quand même
fantastique comment faire pour ne pas
briser justement des réseaux sociaux
comme twitter
c'est pour ça je pense que l'on peut
trouver avec eux des solutions négociées
où il suffit qu'ils désindexer hashtag
manifestants qui sont racistes ou qui
sont antisémites homophobes des trending
topics c puis voilà enfin il ya quelques
il ya eu quelques points sur lesquels je
pense qu'on peut arriver à se mettre
d'accord sans que ce soit ni une aux
travaux à la liberté d'expression y
compris au sens américain du terme au
sens de la constitution américaine du
terme et que ce soit respectueux des
traditions politiques et d'expression un
des pays dans lequel des tweets à robert
et de façon plus générale face à un
facebook qui pèse un milliard
d'utilisateurs saisir la taille
quasiment d'un continent car un pays
comme la france tout est le faire le
poids ou comment dialoguer d'égal à égal
vous savez ça alors moi je pense que la
difficulté en fait des discussions
qu'ils ont avec ces entreprises on sait
que ce sont des entreprises qui ont très
peu de temps les équipes sont assez
réduites en réalité c'est à dire qu'il y
ait tritter sur les toutes petites
équipes et donc pour eux c'est difficile
aussi d'entrer dans une logique de
modération
etc facebook c'est un peu pareil sont
des entreprises qui sont très jeunes ils
sont pas forcément structuré comme comme
que des entreprises traditionnelles avec
des interlocuteurs bien désigné et mais
en même temps la richesse de facebook ce
sont les données dont on parlait tout à
l'heure des personnels ce sont ces se
sont désabonnés et je pense que leur
intérêt bien compris est de s'adapter
aussi aux réalités locales et de traiter
aussi les données personnelles les les
systèmes politiques et de libertés
publiques locaux alors je vais aller
voir sur twitter vous êtes critiqué fin
aux pèlerins parce qu'on vous accuse de
ne pas suffisamment défendre la
neutralité du net ça veut dire obliger
les fournisseurs d'accès à internet de
transmettre toutes les données sans
discrimination sans retenue sans censure
alors vous aviez d'ailleurs annoncer une
loi pendant la campagne présidentielle
qui ne vient pas on avait proposé
d'ouvrir un débat je crois que c'est un
sujet qui est très compliqué parce que
ils mélangent en noir pour la neutralité
du net c'est très sensible pour tous les
internautes
plus précisément comment légiférer sans
revenir sur le principe fondateur de de
la neutralité du net qui est un des
principes là toute la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est que la neutralité du
net n'est pas défini elle n'est pas
défini en droit et donc c'est ça fait
partie d'ailleurs des sujets sur
lesquels certains aimeraient bien qu'on
légifère mais vous parliez tout à
l'heure de brider l'innovation
il faut qu'on fasse très attention et
qu'on soit très vigilant à ne pas
rentrer dans des dispositifs juridiques
qui seraient susceptibles ensuite de
brider l'innovation et pour l'instant la
difficulté qu'on a c'est que cette
neutralité c'est à dire le fait de
pouvoir donner sans discrimination à
tous les utilisateurs accès aux mêmes
contenus quel que soit l'endroit où ils
se trouvent
quelles que soient leurs abonnements
site
c'est à la fois une liberté publique est
quasiment reconnu par la constitution
mais qui n'est pas formalisé comme tel
dans l'andante dans les textes et
aujourd'hui la difficulté qu'on a c'est
que vous avez un versant qui est un
versant aux libertés publiques donc
liberté d'accès aux contenus nos sans
discrimination et de l'autre côté vous à
une réalité économique et physique qui
est que vous certains acteurs en voit de
plus en plus de données sur la bande
passante
contribuer aux usa et au milieu vous
balancez alors c'est vrai mes marques
sur le marché ou en fait vous n'êtes pas
les acteurs économiques sont séparés par
des acteurs qui sont qui se trouve au
milieu et moi je suis je suis plutôt
favorable à ce que les acteurs qui
utilisent énormément de bande passante
et qui oblige les opérateurs à faire des
investissements considérables sur les
réseaux a payé un peu une partie de
l'investissement ou contribuer en tout
cas à l'effort d'investissement qui est
induit par le trafic qui créent eux
mêmes sur sur les raisons visiblement
ils ne veulent pas en entendre parler
c'est pas vraiment dans leur intérêt
économique mais en même temps il faut
trouver un équilibre aussi un moment il
peut pas y avoir ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
by avoir toujours les mêmes qui payent
les impôts sur les sociétés qui payent
la tva qui paye les infrastructures et
puis d'autres qui ne payent jamais rien
ni impôts ni à la contribution à la
financement des contenus et ni
participation au financement des
infrastructures
donc il ya un moment où il faut que
d'une certaine manière il ya une
insertion plus harmonieuse dans
l'écosystème numérique
aujourd'hui c'est pas tout à fait ce
combat on a bien compris en tous les cas
toutes les données un accord une
question une dernière question en
décembre vous avez annoncé ou prou vous
avez lancé disons le un quartier
numérique à la française est une sorte
de silicon valley à la française
quelle poisse à peu d'avoir face à
l'attack vallée à londres et est ce que
ça risque pas d'être un désert au final
parce qu'il ya pas mal de
d'entrepreneurs de ceux qui ont un appel
manqué chalon qui vont elles ont dit
qu'on y vend tout salon il n'ya pas de
fiscalité évidemment ou vos paris 20
pour le début de la mission qu'elle
aurait là bas alors ils peuvent faire
des plus values gigantesque tout pour ya
beaucoup d'intox pjanic pas si vous avez
vu le prix des loyers par exemple je
pense que quand on compte quand on
compare les les les écosystèmes il faut
prendre en compte ce que vous coûte la
scolarisation de vos enfants ce que vous
coûte la santé ce que vous coûter votre
vivant et vais pas massivement
aujourd'hui enfin c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment démontré je pense que les
anglais ont des atouts à faire valoir
qu'ils sont très très bon en
communication je crois que nous nous
avons des entreprises qui sont
formidables avec beaucoup d'innovations
nous avons d'excellents ingénieurs
nous avons d'excellentes infrastructures
et et donc nous avons énormément
d'atouts et je crois que pour l'instant
nous ne communiquons pas suffisamment
sur ses atouts donc c'est bien c'est
bien pour ça d'ailleurs que je j'essaye
de vendre aussi le pacte de
compétitivité à l'international parce
que je crois que nous avons cet effort
de communication et de pédagogie à faire
à l'international
et puis cette idée moi j'aime pas
tellement l'idée de silicon valley à la
française parce que je crois qu'il faut
pas essayé de répliquer des modèles qui
sont qui n'ont rien de comparable
a en france je crois qu'il faut faire
avec les atouts qu'on a et avec et avec
notre créativité particulière dont moi
je pense est important qu'il y ait une
vitrine une vitrine de l'innovation
technologique en france et je crois
beaucoup à la vertu de la proximité je
voudrais pas d'avoir des candidats
français qui rêvent mais j'en ai déjà
beaucoup qui se manifestent on est déjà
beaucoup manifestent on verra ce
quartier du mas bientôt bientôt bientôt
bon on suit on va observer sa merci
tupac
si la mort est avec eux ce soir perrine
tarneaud de public sénat arrive on va
parler de vous maintenant pour qu'enfin
on le fait déjà avec alexandra colinot
sur la photo du gouvernement elle se
tient discrète au dernier rang nouvelle
dans cette famille encore inconnu il ya
quelques mois sur la scène politique car
fleur pellerin n'est pas un pur produit
du parti socialiste la ministre est
plutôt un modèle de parcours académique
l'essec sciences po l'ena
puis la cour des comptes un parcours de
technocrates qui prend des notes comme
elle le dit elle même
ils ont été mieux si elle avait un socle
électoral à territoire maintenant je je
je
c'est à elle qu'il faut poser la
question mais je pense que si elle a
envie de rester en politique de
s'installer en politique
effectivement il faut penser à cette
hypothèse a pas de terrain donc mais
trois campagnes présidentielles à
inscrire à son cv
tour à tour plumes dans l'équipe de
lionel jospin en 2002 responsable de la
presse spécialisée dans l'équipe de
ségolène royal en 2007
enfin en 2012 elle rejoint l'équipe de
françois hollande
parrainée par pierre moscovici et
surtout par son mari laurent olléon
conseiller d'état très proche du
candidat
elle intègre le gouvernement certes pour
ses compétences dans le domaine du
numérique mais aussi pour la diversité
qu'elle représente la vision politique
de la diversité et cette vision
politique c'est plutôt lié au processus
de renouvellement des élites dans notre
pays la corée la corée est une
je pense pour l'instant dans sa tête
c'est une
émotion touristique et la haute saône a
aucun élément de langage et connaît pas
la civilisation qu elle est autant
millénaire donc voilà donc je pense
qu'effectivement des coréens sont très
fiers d'avoir une femme d'origine
coréenne et accède un petit peu au
pouvoir au gouvernement de la france
mais sinon ce qui la concerne et les
professeurs profondément française fleur
pellerin a d'ailleurs prévu de se rendre
en corée du sud en début d'année premier
voyage dans son pays de naissance
ce sera un grand événement pour vous
alors soir effectivement en corée où
vous êtes une star ce qui est pas mal de
portrait publié de vous pendant la
campagne présidentielle et puis depuis
que vous êtes un ministre qu'est ce que
ce pays représente pour vous aujourd'hui
est ce que c'est un pays étranger c'est
un pays étranger oui comme une liste et
étrangers pour vous mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya un lien particulier qui bien
sûr qu'ils qui existent pas que s'est
créée mais qui existe de fait parce que
j'y suis né et parce que je pense les
coréens sont effectivement très fier
d'eux ils sont attachés au droit du sang
sont très fiers de voir quelqu'un qui
est né en corée accéder à des fonctions
gouvernementales dans un pays étranger
c'est quelque chose qui leur paraît
assez inédit parce que même jean vincent
placé inquiets sénateurs présents les
groupes écologistes et ici au sénat
avait été accueillie avec beaucoup de
ferveur et c'était oui c'est une société
qui a assez peu intégratrice et donc
c'est vrai que à la fois le parcours de
jean vincent placé est le mien ont
réouvert des débats sur la capacité
d'intégration de la société coréenne
avec aussi des questions sur des
insultes dont a été victime une
parlementaire d'origine philippine au
moment des dernières législatives donc
je crois qu'il ya voilà ça et ça a
ouvert un débat public sur l'intégration
un pays qui ne reconnaît pas
spécialement votre intérêt jusqu'à
présent jusqu'à une date récente
c'est à dire que j'ai fait j'ai toujours
grandi en france je me suis rendu à
plusieurs reprises et pour des raisons
professionnelles ou de stage au japon en
chine à hong kong
donc j'ai toujours mais jamais jamais je
vais donc c'est vrai que ce sera amusant
de de pouvoir de pouvoir retourner dans
ce pays alors j'y vais évidemment avec
une casquette nouvelles technologies
promotion du pacte pour la compétitivité
mais sur tous ces points la corée peut
être un exemple pour la france
absolument c'est pour ça que c'est
particulièrement intéressant parce
qu'évidemment il ya des entreprises qui
sont vraiment intéressantes pour des
partenariats de recherche d'innovation
avec nos entreprises alors fort pèlerins
carrière éclair en politique parce que
finalement vous cachiez toutes les
bonnes cases
vous êtes jeune dette une femme vous
êtes une représentante de la diversité
est ce que ça vous gêne finalement de
devoir votre nomination au gouvernement
à ces critères là bas je croise les
doigts pas ces critères là je pense que
je les dois aussi ça a dû jouer mon jeu
des tonneaux si je pense que je les dois
surtout au fait que j'étais à la cour
des comptes et que j'avais quelques
connaissances en finances publiques que
je suis capable de rentrer dans les
dossiers ont des dossiers de notamment
très technique je m'en charge du secteur
des télécoms du secteur du chantier du
très haut débit sont des secteurs qui
sont extrêmement complexes et je pense
que c'est aussi ma capacité à
appréhender des dossiers complexes qui a
fait que j'ai été nommé je pense que si
je n'avais que cocher la case le cloud
mais les républicains ont persisté genre
je pense pas du tout que j'aurais été
nommé à ce moment là enfin je fais
crédit à jean marc ayrault et à françois
hollande de ne pas avoir uniquement
mis en avant ces critères la messe que
malgré vous représentez un symbole parce
qu'on a l'impression
peut-être peut-être en tout cas si je
pense que c'est pas c'est pas enfin
disons mothern unis je pense le la
raison principale de ma présence au
gouvernement mais est ce que ça vous
gêne ou est-ce que vous assumez d'être
toujours décrite finalement autour de
ces critères de diversité d'adoption de
pareilles ça a été vrai impôt des bus
aller moi maintenant je pense que
maintenant les gens qui s'intéressent à
moi s'intéresse plus à ce que je fais
est ce que je représente est chouette
symboliser donc je crois que maintenant
on est vraiment rentré dans dans dans
les dossiers et que
voilà l'étonnement ou l'intérêt mort
d'homme au début ouais un peu les
innovations ouais mais c'est vrai que
chez certains qui étaient engagés depuis
longtemps un politique et notamment au
sein des partis ces listes ont pu avoir
certaines jalousies de vous voir accéder
si facilement au gouvernement alors que
vous pensez l'élection est déjà aussi à
une volonté du président de la
république pendant la campagne en tout
cas d'ouvrir l'équipe
l'équipe de campagne à des personnes qui
ne soit pas tout
façonné sur le même modèle et et et
d'intégrer aussi des personnes qui
avaient pas le même profil qui n'étaient
pas forcément dans des carrières
politiques depuis depuis des années
alors je ne dis pas que la question ne
se posera pas plus tard d'ailleurs elle
s'est déjà posée puisque on m'a proposé
d'être candidate aux élections
législatives dans des circonscriptions
effectivement absolument et je trouvais
que c'était c'est pas le bon tempo c'est
à dire que comme vous l'avez dit tout
s'est passé quand même relativement vite
même si j'avais commencé déjà en 97 à
faire campagne auprès de jospin donc
c'est pas le moine en 2007
c'est pas non plus un engagement
opportuniste de la dernière minute mais
la politique était peut-être pas assez
viscérale pour s'engager sur le terrain
non mais au début je crois que vous
savez j'ai fait je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de façons s'engager c'est
quelque chose que je dis souvent mais
j'y crois beaucoup moi je me suis
beaucoup engagé dans l'associatif et je
pense qu'il ya on est dans l'opposition
j'ai fait les campagnes qui sont des
moments que se cristallisent le débat
politique mais je me suis engagé
beaucoup dans dans des actions de
terrain associative et c'est aussi une
façon de s'engager citoyenne politique
qu'ils pouvaient répondre aussi à mon
souhait de participer à l'intérêt
général
au delà d'ailleurs de ma profession qui
était tout entière tournée vers le
service chronique et l'intérêt général à
vous la légitimité en politique ne vient
pas uniquement du suffrage universel
je pense qu'à un moment la question se
pose très avec insistance mais pour vous
ce juin 2014
on verra on verra pour l'instant moi ce
qui m'importe c'est vraiment de faire
bien le travail qui m'a été confié je
crois que c'est ça qui attendent nos
concitoyens et c'est pas le calcul sur
ses classes sur sa carrière
je crois que la situation est
suffisamment difficile en ce moment pour
que l'on fasse passer les priorités
d'intérêt collectif d'intérêt général
avant ses priorités personnelles
qu'est ce qui vous surprend le plus dans
le monde politique sans doute il ya des
petits moments d exacerbation des
tensions
quand on est dans des missions que j'ai
par exemple où on parle toujours
beaucoup de la violence effectivement
politique virage verbal et c'est vrai
qu'il ya des moments où ça se
cristalliser quand quand vous êtes dans
l'hémicycle à l'assemblée nationale où
en fait le temps de débat et quand même
les questions sont courtes et les
réponses trop courte
donc il faut il ya une espèce de mise en
exergue de des oppositions détention et
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qui
est un peu surprenant pour pour qu'ils
n'étaient pas entrés dans l'hémicycle
avant en tant que député le moment du
gouvernement c'est surprenant
le gai on nous disait ici la semaine
dernière qu effectivement ce qui l'a
gardée dessous fin le pire souvenir pour
lui c'était les séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement à
l'assemblée nationale ce moment le plus
dur pour lui à vivre dans sa carrière
politique
ouais je pense que c'est un moment
d'exposition qui est ce qui est assez
violent effectivement quand on n'y est
pas quand on n'y est pas préparé alors
après la tension diminuer puis on
s'habitue
c'est c'est très scénographié mais c'est
vrai que la violence est palpable
parfois enfin l'agressivité peut être
palpable
et c'est quelque chose qui est assez
surprenant mais je pense pour quelqu'un
qui est issue la fonction publique comme
commune tech le gain comme on a beaucoup
aussi parlé de bisbee à bercy entre
plusieurs ministres est ce que ça aussi
ça vous a surpris ses relations
compliquées entre collègues du
gouvernement
je crois que c'est ça mon âge je crois
que c'est surtout un sujet d'amusement
pour pour bien c'est une réalité un qui
est un menu par plusieurs ministres et
quand même des tensions il ya des
désaccords parfois ce que je disais tout
à l'heure le gouvernement et divers ça
ne vous aura pas échappé il ya plusieurs
composantes c'est une majorité plurielle
il ya des sensibilités qui sont
différentes
et quand ya des sensibilités différentes
voies parfois il ya des discussions car
cette session vous avez exprimé la même
opinion qu arnaud montebourg sur renault
voilà le champ de notre guillemets à la
compétitivité
sur ce point la roma en tout cas et la
vie mention masculine reste fort trop
forte pour vous dans le milieu politique
oui elle est assez fort c'est vrai que
je vous dis parfois quand je vois les
horaires des réunions ou des auditions
que c'est pas trés family friendly comme
disent les anglo saxons c'est pas trés
c'est pas très favorable un bon
équilibre vie privée vie familiale en
tout cas et vie professionnelle
alors il faut sacrifier votre vie privée
oui oui oui bah oui c'est c1 c'est un
travail qui est extrêmement
qui est extrêmement chronophage en temps
mais aussi en mobilisation de l'esprit
donc c'est vrai que même quand je rentre
chez moi souvent ma fille me dit mais là
je téléphone arrête de répondre et c'est
vrai que c'est difficile de décrocher
difficile de décrocher mais bon voilà je
savais aussi en acceptant l'honneur
qu'on me faisait me confiera impasse au
gouvernement que c'était une certaine
façon en sacrifice à consentir pendant
quelques années on dit souvent que c'est
un cdd un poste de deux ministres voilà
j'avais fait plusieurs campagnes avant
j'avais fait le choix de rentrer dans
l'équipe de campagne officielle donc
c'était aussi c'était aussi un choix
bien raisonné il réfléchit pour finir
j'ai envie de vous demander à quand une
vraie politique éducative pour les
enfants sur les réseaux sociaux
l'académie des sciences a publié
aujourd'hui un avis qui incite à une
autorégulation des parents mais est ce
que cette cette éducation des enfants on
ne peut pas se faire aussi à l'école oui
pourquoi pas la cnil a d'ailleurs il ne
désemplit les clapistes hawsawi la cnil
a développé des programmes de
sensibilisation pour pour les jeunes
pour les enfants qui sont faits en
partenariat avec l'éducation nationale
donc c'est tout à fait possible en
vitesse mais c'est le rôle des pouvoirs
publics de l'école ou des parents
simplement bas je crois que ça peut être
très bien une responsabilité partagée je
pense qu'il ya des parents qui sont eux
mêmes utilisateurs et qui connaissent
bien la façon dont fonctionne sur soi
dépassée par la voilà lorsque certains
parents sont dépassés et je pense qu'on
sera enfin moi j'en chie agilité à 8 ans
déjà déjà très très élevé sur les si
c'était vrai je vous le dirai pas pour
vous les aspects positifs l'emportent
sur les aspects négatifs non mais c'est
vrai et c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'il
faut réguler enfin moi je régule en tout
cas je pense que quand on n'est pas bien
informés c'est bien d'avoir un soutien
aussi du système éducatif pour pour
aider à cette régulation c'est vrai que
vous avez un humour au deuxième au
troisième voire au quatrième degré mais
attention parce que parce que parfois
c'est pas le troisième ça passe pas
toujours très bien se passe pas et puis
ça passe toujours très bien en 140
signes quand on est sur twitter c'est
vrai que twitter ça exige quand même un
mode d'expression qui est particulier
parce que c'est très très court et
parfois on fait des blagues si on n'a
pas mis le petit smiley qui qui va avec
c'est mal interprété donc je fais plus
attention maintenant bien entre
ministres quand même on a suffisamment
agile pour comprendre le quatrième degré
et oui en train du nist donc à la finale
à bercy
très bonnes relations avec tous merci il
fera merci perrine merci à vous bonsoir
a très vite
en 20 ans napoléon iii des travaux
gigantesques ont fait de paris la
capitale que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui notamment en créant deux
grands axes le centre de paris cette à
l'île de la cité essentiellement et
comme on pouvait plus circuler dans le
centre le seul moyen c'était de rentrer
de nouvelles circulations maître
d'oeuvre de cette métamorphose
le baron haussmann préfet de paris de
1853 à 1870 partout où il est passé il y
a eu des progrès cette espèce de
locomotive lancée à pleine vitesse dans
un siècle qui s'interroge c'est
probablement l'image la plus belle
comment haussmann à transformer paris
samedi à 22h sur public sénat
bonjour à tous bienvenue à banne ce
merveilleux village reculé sur tous
perchés quelque part dans le sud de
l'ardèche ici une bataille a marqué le
pays à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale une embuscade hardiment menées
par les partisans les résistants c'était
à quelques kilomètres d'ici
dans la vallée une bataille d'envergure
qui a stoppé net la progression d'une
importante colonne allemande en route
vers le nord du pays
un homme occupe une place très
singulière dans cet épisode de
l'histoire cet homme c'est paul maës il
était maire du village
en ce mois de juillet 1944 et depuis
très peu de temps depuis moins d'un an
la toute nouvelle école de ban porte
désormais son nom
voilà je me trouve maintenant dans cette
magnifique salle de classe de la toute
nouvelle école de banal un an et demi à
peine j'ai rejoins l'un des professeurs
de l'école frédéric le claj bonjour
bonjour avec devant vous et bien vos
élèves aux enfants une classe de cm2 cm1
bonjour à tous alors frédéric leclerc
cette école s'appelle paul maes est ce
que c'est un nom que vous connaissiez il
ya encore quelques mois je n'ai
découvert quand ils ont nommé cette
école et auparavant n'étant pas moi-même
debanne auparavant je ne connaissais pas
du tout ce personnage vous avez
peut-être regarder les plaques qui sont
sur l'école elle même est ce que vous
êtes intéressé à ce personnage de bob à
partir de ce moment là j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à me demander d'abord
qu'est-ce qu'il avait bien pu faire et
puis d'où venait ce nom si qui n'est pas
un patronyme d'origine ardéchoise
française et donc j'ai fait quelques
recherches
alors votre école les enfants elle
s'appelle paul maz est ce que ce nom
vous le connaissez est ce que ça vous
dit quelque chose
bah j'ai pas connue mais c'était le
maire de vannes 2-2 ce que ce que j'ai
écouté ce que j'ai entendu dans ici
alors paul maïs il était maire de bad
mais quand quand il ya eu la bataille de
ban et c'était quand ça
en 1804 quarante quatre pôles maïs était
maire en 1944 c'est à dire pendant la
guerre pendant la guerre oui la seconde
guerre mondiale il l'a sauvé le village
il était maire il là il lâche hervé la
carélie ce temps et là il a combattu
également et c'est bien ce qui la fait
pas de mal je trouve ça éric leclerc
merci beaucoup de nous avoir accueillis
chez vous dans votre salle de classe
sinon qu'il vous remercions à très
bientôt on va essayer maintenant d'en
savoir un peu plus sur paul maes et sur
cette fameuse bataille de bam merci les
enfants à très bientôt au revoir
alors vous l'avez compris en cette fin
du mois de juillet 1944 paul maes le
maire de bam n'est pas tout à fait un
personnage comme les autres son action
elle intervient quelques jours à peine
après ce qu'on appelle ici la bataille
de ban autrement dit la plus grande
bataille de la résistance ici dans le
département la neige
je rejoint raul galatto il est historien
c'est l'un des meilleurs spécialistes de
cette résistance ardéchoise
bonjour à houlgate haut escaut and
aujourd'hui ensemble au village tel
qu'il existait en juillet 1944 pour
l'échangé louit avec son aspect
pittoresque le juger sur sa colline le
rochers calcaires les chais ruines du
vieux château bon il ya des quelques
maisons nouvelles mais pour l'essentiel
oui c'est très typique
ban a joué un rôle tout à fait
particulier dans cette résistance
ardéchoise eh oui ban se trouve situé en
bordure d'une route à l'époque aux
routes nationales qui avait une
importance stratégique pour les armées
allemandes d'occupation dans tout le sud
de la france y compris le languedoc et
les volontaires des forces françaises de
l'intérieur c'est à dire les forces
armées de la résultante ont été amenés à
livrer quelques escarmouches contre auch
et congo allemand qui cherche qu l'est
qui étaient ces résistants qui ont
participé à la bataille de bain des
jeunes volontaires paysans et autres de
la région de bâle ont rejoints par des
maquisards ftp venus du gard
principalement des ouvriers mineurs dans
des cévennes il ya eu
évidemment parmi les réfugiés qui ont
rejoint la résistance plusieurs l'ancien
républicains espagnols
on a retrouvé dans cette compagnie aussi
donc c'était très diversifié bon au
départ il y avait quelques centaines de
volontaires le 6 juin
fin juillet devait y avoir cinq ou six
mille volontaires dans le département de
l'ardèche qui était organisé en compagne
et donc encadré convenablement on avait
trouvé quand même quelques militaires
des anciens qui avait fait la guerre
14-18 tous acquis près qu'ils avaient
quelques compétences c'est ce qui leur a
permis de livrer un combat qui
finalement était le premier combat
victorieux à en ardèche qui a précédé de
quelques jours la libération de privas
la première préfecture de france libérée
par la résistance le 12 août
avant même le débarquement des troupes
alliées les côtes méditerranéennes
ce qui a été tout à l'honneur de la
résistance ardéchoise merci beaucoup
raul galatto vous le disiez à l'instant
même
cette bataille de ban intervient dans un
contexte particulier les alliés ont
débarqué en normandie
deux mois avant le 6 juin 1944 le
débarquement de provence n'a pas encore
eu lieu il y aura lieu le 15 août de
cette même année